Selena Gomez is taking a break to focus  on her health  in a statement to ET salinas says the  hiatus stems from anxiety panic attacks  and depression all a result of her lupus  diagnosis she adds quote I want to be  proactive and focus on maintaining my  health and happiness and have decided  that the best way forward is to take  some time off I always felt that from  the people I'm involved with her or  support me can just kind of spread love  within that you know it's hard the 24  year old first revealed she had lupus  last year and says she's facing this  head-on it makes you really your life  sometimes a source close to the former  Disney star tells ET the singer hasn't  felt like herself lately and that this  is absolutely not  alcohol or substance abuse related  Selena's been on her revival tour for  months and she's been absent from social  media since her brief Instagram feud  with her ex Justin Bieber almost three  weeks ago